roll the credits
[Music]
i man okay
so you already know what i'm gonna talk
about because it's in the title of the
video
unless you clicked on this completely
randomly in which case hi welcome please
like share subscribe hit the bell
support me on patreon
but look i
thought i was prepped for this i thought
i
knew what i was getting into i was
commissioned to review this through
patreon
actually a while back and i kind of been
putting it off for no particular reason
i just did other stuff first and i got i
finally got around to this thing
what did i just watch okay
so starchaser the legend of oren
this was a film that i knew really only
because nostalgia critic did
a video review of it a while back
so before i stopped watching channel
awesome
i did see that now i didn't remember a
ton about it
but it looked bad and it was clearly a
star wars ripoff
but like i did not understand the degree
to which this thing rips off star wars
nor did i
understand the full level of
bats that goes on in this thing
okay so a little bit of context
this thing was it's an animated film it
was released in 1985. there were a ton
of things that ripped off star wars in
the 80s if you're gonna try and rip off
star wars
without having the budget that star wars
did
especially by the time it wrapped up
with the return of the jedi
then honestly going animated is probably
a good
idea because for the amount of money
that could get you
super wobbly sets and really sketchy
visual effects
you can just draw it and have whatever
you want
so the initial concept of let's
animate our star wars rip-off honestly
not a bad idea
but there's a couple of things where you
guessed it first off
it's rotoscoped now if you don't know
rotoscoping means they filmed actors and
then when they did the animation
they are basically tracing over them now
there's still animation involved in that
they um in the drawing portion they do a
lot of embellishments that weren't
there on the on the live action actors
but you
end up getting very fluid lifelike
movements sometimes to the point of
uncanny valley
without having to worry a ton about
getting exceptionally high level
animation talent
because they're tracing more than they
are drawing from scratch
but one of the problems with rotoscoping
is it tends to
really limit the kinds of shots that end
up being used in the film
because in animation you can do all
kinds of shots that you can't get in
practical
filmmaking but the minute you bring
rotoscoping in you're limited to what
you can film
actors doing in terms of angles and all
this other stuff and suddenly the film
is a lot less visually interesting than
it should be in animation but
i'm getting weirdly like technical and
almost high-minded like
here are some of the philosophical
problems with rotoscoping let's
dig into this freaking thing shall we
obviously the term star wars ripoff has
been used
uh more than a few times already in this
review um
it is it is across the board it is
broad strokes it is aesthetic it is
specifics it is
like disturbingly specific at times but
let's see what i can remember
that was like clearly all lifted first
off you have
direct analogs like to the point of
having
nearly identical function and
characterization
super close analogs to luke
han leia obi-wan you have a sassy robot
although it happens to be a ship
this time as opposed to just being a
robot although you do also have a robot
we'll come back to her you have a
helmeted villain
and then you've got weirdly oddly super
specific stuff
like the villain lifting up and choking
somebody to death
within the opening of the movie and what
basically is this film's equivalent of
help me obi-wan kenobi you're my only
hope except it's obi-wan kenobi
delivering the dang message
dag who is the han ripoff his
ship it's not shaped like the millennium
falcon but from the back it looks like
the millennium falcon
these things even have the same effect
when they go into light speed and
i swear they even lifted some of the
sound effects
oh and there's also a sword that seems
to retract into its hilt
yeah let's just toss that in there as
well and that one took me a second to
catch because the wrinkle in that is
initially
oren finds this sword and like just
finds it randomly
it's in the dirt he's a miner and he
finds it and
and it's just a hilt and he's like i
must find the blade but there are times
where he swings it
and it seems to kill people and so it's
like
it's a light saber with a retractable
blade but when the blade is extended is
also invisible
is basically out functions and at first
i thought the invisible blade was like
oh that's kind of neat then i realized
that it was clearly retracting and going
back in like oh no it's just a
lightsaber that you can't
see all right let's let's start talking
about some of these characters okay so
why don't we start with oren there
wasn't a lot to say oren
is bland as hell he might be one of the
blandest protagonists since
i don't know jen from the original dark
crystal movie
and not only bland stupid there's a
reason
for that which is he comes from these
people who are trapped in a mine and
are used are there they labor until they
die they don't know anything other than
the mind he escapes that so obviously
he doesn't really know anything about
the world at large around him that's
fine that gives him plenty of reason to
ask lots of questions
except he asks questions that aren't
specific to this unique world they're
just like
what's a robot what's a patrol he
actually says he actually has that
what's a patrol
[Music]
like thank god that question doesn't
actually get answered as if the audience
actually needed that explained to him
but you set him up to be an audience
sergey because he doesn't know that much
about that world and he's not asking the
vital questions how do these things that
are unique to this world work
he doesn't know what money is and he
doesn't know what a guard patrol is
that's not helpful and it sure as hell
isn't funny he seems to be motivated
purely by
what other people say he should do
mostly by people who die
fairly soon after he has virtually no
agency of his own he just gets shuttled
around from point to point
he's useless and uninteresting and just
blah so there's dag
who's our han equivalent and oh okay
he is trying very hard to be the cooler
one
he is more morally dubious he's got a
cigar
hey he's this kind of guy but
he i'm trying to think if there's a
tactful way to say this there
isn't he
he anally violates a robot to wipe her
free will and then sells her into
slavery
that that's not even me editorializing
that is
factually what happens early on they
kidnap what is
described in universe as a fembot
it's just a robot why the heck would you
build it like that
she has her own personality she has her
own mind she is objecting to this she
says you're kidnapping me you don't do
this
and he is poking around in her trying to
reprogram her
so she won't be a problem for them and
he asked his ship for advice on where
her personality circuits are
the ship tells them they're in her
posterior
he opens up her very
shapely robotic butt and forcibly pokes
around in it
until he brainwashes her so she no
longer has a problem and now she's
suddenly in love with him and then as
soon as they land the
ship he sends her to the auction house
so he can get a cut
of her sale i'm not exaggerating
i'm not adding anything that's just what
he does and this character whose name i
cannot remember so i'm just gonna refer
to her as fembot
fembot does come back into the fold and
she remains
creepily in love with dag
for the rest of the movie this is never
addressed
the fact that he wiped out her free will
and that her
desire for him is completely artificial
and forced never brought up not even
once not even in passing
and then then there's discount layup
she doesn't show up really meaningfully
until halfway into the movie so i can't
remember what the heck her name is
she's discount leia she gets introduced
briefly up at the auction where the
fembot is being put up for set
moving on and she shows up then about
halfway into the movie
like helping oren after oren crashes
so she finds out what hit what's going
on with him
for what he's saying and everything
going on it's not worth trying to
explain everything it's more complicated
than it needs to be and it's not that
interesting for it
she comes to the determination that she
can't tell her father what's going on
because
she can't be certain that he will help
so she steals a ship
does not tell her father where she's
going goes on a mission to
help oren free his people which means
she's basically going to start a prison
riot
and we find out none of this was done
because she wanted to help
i didn't take you back here because i
wanted to help
you for your people
i i did it for me
because i wanted to be with you
i yelled at the tv i said lady do you
even know his last
name cause i don't and i've spent more
time with him than you
have what the hell
and and and oren's totally
reciprocal which i would be as
fine as that kind of thing could
possibly be
except like his girlfriend that he was
pining for
died like what yesterday
and you're prepared to make out with
wait
what there isn't really much to say
about the villain he's basically darth
vader and reverse well no he's like he's
like a russian doll darth vader because
it starts out with a big helmet takes
the helmet off he's just a dude
and then later on gets smashed up and
the dude's a robot so instead of looking
like a robot but being a person he looks
like a person but he is a robot
who cares he's not interesting although
he does like as soon as he captures oren
initially when oren's trying to flee the
mines
he actually says you will die with the
secret
you might as well know the rest of the
lie really
dude you just said flat out this the
first time in 1200 years anyone has been
any kind of this sort of problem for you
at all and you're gonna chat his ear off
about
whatever it is you've been spending foul
over a thousand years trying to hide
look those are the major things but like
i just got to go through a list of other
stuff that
that just happens and i gotta go through
it oren tells a blind kid
to run yeah good advice buddy apparently
the lead villain who's like building an
army to take over the universe also
responds to minor incidents at the front
door
personally a bit of star wars ripping
off that i missed they completely joint
the entire diving of the millennium
falcon
inside the second death star thing
there's this weird little fairy thing
that it one of the things that it does
to help them out is basically make a
robot
shoot itself in the head and it's not
quick
it's like the slow raising up and aiming
and wha
what and finally we can end it all off
with a nice dash of casual racism
wow if you want to suffer through this
thing
it's viewable for free on this site
on youtube i'll put a link in the
description don't watch it
but that's starchaser
the legend of oren
my god if you want to see me suffer
you can you can commission me to review
stuff
through the patreon you can also support
me in any amount
on the patreon all of that helps um
it's what's keeping the lights on right
now and
like share subscribe all that stuff
comments down in the description
comments down below whatever leave your
thoughts we'll talk about it
but you don't have to do any of it i i
can't even think
right now much less tell you what to do
you're the council i just run the
meetings and until next time this
council
is adjourned oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hmm
um
[Music]